about Benedict every time you're on the
show we get so many messages and tweets
and emails right from your now they're
not cumber anymore they change
name every time I'm on what are they now
cumbers I don't know I'm making it up
do you know what you are
a couple of people Collective people
bunches uh Brands babes it's like
they're not a group anymore
there's definitely some splintering
going on there's a lot of specific okay
so there's a bunch of questions that I'm
actually obliged to ask you so uh so
obviously when we see more Sherlock uh
I think yeah okay are you in the next
Star Trek
no comment okay
why are you in the new Star Wars movie
no comments
of course I'm not I know I heard a rumor
I heard a rumor you were seen around the
set I think I just said which was
fantastic I mean it was like walking
through my childhood and Harrison whose
place I'm honored enough to be in on the
sofa it was yeah he wasn't there
I walked to them alone in fork and I sat
down I mean it was incredible
even saying this I probably should be
saying this on television
we know wind acting it because it fell
on his foot so that's right yeah so
that's right that's right that's already
been spoiled but did you not ask
yourself or something no comment
are you are you at the back of one of
those people unbelievable
you were here with Harrison Ford before
you did an incredible Chewbacca but I'm
told you also do a Jar Jar Binks
no that's a big
spider
you don't make much money out of doing a
good charger let me tell you that
I've ever rightfully slow in my opinion
yeah and uh as about the dragon is back
he is uh aggressively finished business
and I read that that as a voice but
there isn't I mean obviously it's put
through treatments and things but
actually yes it sounds very like
what you did
God do you want me to do that as well
you can
um
beating
faster
I'm terrifying an equal measure I'm very
confused right now
is that
yeah I know yeah does that hurt no but I
feel quite faint
this is odd of all the questions we had
the one that came up most often was
asked Benedict to say the word penguin
what is this about well apparently I got
it wrong repeatedly in the documentary
it wasn't a documentary about said
animal it was uh
documentary about I think about the
South Pacific in general and now I'm
completely terrified of the words
um I Don't Go Near it because I know
here's the thing I thought or so they're
making it up but we actually look you've
got it
the documentaries are called strange
Island the first one you sort of get
away with and then after that you lose
all sense
let's let's have a look listen carefully
and the last thing you might expect to
see here
England crested Penguins named after
this corner of South New Zealand
so why are these woodlands so attractive
to penguins
a freshwater streamed through the forest
makes a handy Highway for a parrot
penguin heading home from the fishing
trip
the funny thing is you don't you don't
do this in isolation you have it you
have a team of you know Natural History
experts based in Bristol funded by you
the tax paying public it's not just me
sitting there at a booth going I think I
know how to say penguin I'd say penguins
we're mortifying but there are other
people who should take something
at the end of the day could we just try
the word penguin again maybe maybe
they just gave up
but then what I love is in the way that
life is how special that Benedict is now
starring oh yeah as a wolf in this film
so can you say it now well I've had a
word with Disney I just I need to check
that I have said it correctly uh
and Gwen the penguin
she's all over it
the sense of achievement
oh yeah do it do it do it yeah
nice nice